well obviously I guess all car makers
will say the same which is we don't want
we don't want tariffs and we think we
should avoid tariffs and they're bad for
everybody so I would say it whether it
is in my old job as a as a manufacturer
from outside of the UK or in my current
job as a manufacturer in the UK of the
UK company tariffs are just bad for
business and that applies whether it's
to the EU whether it's to America or
whether it's to China
the best thing that we can do is not
have to to worry about you know hedging
whether this Harrier is going to go up
or this barrier it's always going to be
better for us if we know that this was
free trade what proportion of the supply
chain comes from outside the UK about
60% so quite quite a lot ultimately of
course we add a lot of value being a
hand-built car we had about 200 hours
per car of value inside the Aston Martin
facility so that the total cost isn't
proportional to the to the supply base
but but so ultimately a weaker pound
does help us but obviously that could
easily get offset if if a WTO level of
tariffs went into place so in other
words if we did revert to a WTO system
that would be cost increases would you
have to pass those on to your customers
inevitably everybody will try to do that
I mean that's somewhat dependent upon
the market but but you already see car
manufacturers importing cars to the UK
now talking about putting their prices
up and that's just based on the back of
Forex of course I would expect the
tariff barrier would get passed on the
Society of motor manufacturers and
traders has said today that it
anticipates the cost of cars rising by
between two and three percent as result
of the drop in the Pande does that
benefit you as a domestic manufacturer
when you're trying to sell to British
customers yes it would and then if we
pass it on obviously we predominantly
manufacturing in impound and we
predominantly sell in the UK impound so
in that case there's less pressure on us
so if we follow the market then
obviously that would result in a better
bottom line or perhaps we can we we
don't have to push as much as much as
maybe we would and that would be benefit
to our cars
summers as we go overseas then basically
at the moment of what we see is is we're
benefiting on on that transaction on to
our bottom line as you say one of your
main export markets is United States
Donald Trump is clearly trying to
encourage more manufacturing production
within the United States
where does that leave you well our
volume isn't big enough to justify
manufacturing in two places at once so
we have to kind of see how that how that
rolls out hopefully you know if one
believes the rhetoric in the UK and the
US could put together a trade agreement
and hopefully that would be to the
benefit of Aston Martin